My name is Daniel Donoghue.
I'm a Professor of English,
and the Chair of the Committee
on Medieval Studies.
Diagrams are ubiquitous.
There is the
mandala, for example,
used in Buddhist meditation.
Or the mandorla, used in
Byzantine and Western Christian
iconography.
But we don't have
to go so far afield.
I can recall, for example, the
seductive symmetry of diagrams
in textbooks from my earlier
school days in fields
like geometry and biology.
In more recent
decades, computers
have allowed us to
turn many kinds of data
into visual representations
of various kinds of data,
including 3-D imaging.
If we think of diagrams as
techniques of visualization
that give order to knowledge
and perception, then
the Middle Ages have a special
claim on our attention,
because much of its
art is diagrammatic.
We might be tempted to dismiss
diagrams as a convenience,
perhaps visually
interesting, but still
a tool that recedes into
the background behind more
pressing questions.
But as our talk this
evening will demonstrate,
the topic opens into important
philosophical and aesthetic
questions such as,
what is an image?
Jeffrey Hamburger is the
Kuno Franke Professor
of German Art and
Culture at the Department
of the History of Art and
Architecture, here at Harvard.
The recipient of grants
from numerous organizations,
including the John S. Guggenheim
Foundation, the American
Philosophical Society, the
NEH, and the Humboldt-Stiftung,
Professor Hamburger
was elected a Fellow
of the Medieval Academy
of America in 2001,
and a member of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences
in 2009.
He is the author, the co-author,
the editor and the co-editor,
of too many books to list in
an introduction like this.
So I will mention only
a few from recent years.
I hope all of you had
the opportunity last year
to visit the stunning exhibition
of medieval illuminated
manuscripts, held in various
institutions in the Boston
area.
They were assembled
and displayed
at the Isabella
Stewart Gardner Museum,
at the McMullen Museum
of Boston College,
and here at the
Houghton Library.
Professor Hamburger was one of
the prime movers of the effort,
and a co-editor of the
beautiful volume to accompany
the exhibition--
Beyond Words--
illuminated manuscripts
in Boston Collections.
Also in 2016, with
three collaborators,
he produced Liturgical Life and
Latin Learning at Paradies Bei
Soest, 1300-1425--
Inscription and
Illumination and the Choir
Books of a North German
Dominican Convent.
In 2015, with Nigel Palmer,
he edited The Prayer Book
of Ursula Begerin.
And between 2015 and 2016, he
produced a 12-volume survey
of masterpieces of book
illumination in central Europe.
In 2016, with Harvard
University Press,
he co-edited Sign and Design--
Script as Image in
Cross-cultural Perspective,
300 to 1600 CE.
Next April, Professor
Hamburger is
organizing a symposium
at Dumbarton Oaks,
on the Diagram Paradigm--
Byzantium, the Latin West,
and the Islamic World.
As the Chair of the Committee
on Medieval Studies,
I am constantly reminded
that to be a Medievalist
means to be interdisciplinary.
And that interdisciplinarity
is even more true,
if that's possible, in the
field of Medieval Art History.
Professor Hamburger's
scholarship
moves with disarming ease among
various specialized fields,
such as Late Medieval
Theology, including
Mysticism, liturgy,
Latin and vernacular
literature, and history--
whether the micro-history of a
particular convent in Bavaria,
or the particular interest in--
or, I should say,
the broader movements
of political and
cultural history.
His work has shown a
particular interest
in women's spirituality
and mysticism, especially
in convents throughout
the German-speaking world,
with special attention
to book illuminations.
But his work is always
reaching toward big questions,
so that when he examines
a particular instance
of mystical art produced in a
Bavarian convent, for example,
he crosses a threshold into
a much broader discussion
of the paradoxical relationship
between art and mysticism.
This evening, we are
going to be treated
to a similar move, that opens
onto important questions facing
us today.
Finally, let me say, it is a
special pleasure for me to make
this introduction, because
Jeffrey and I have been friends
since our graduate school days.
He will be speaking to us
on mind mapping, diagrams
in the Middle Ages, and beyond.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much, Dan,
for that more than generous
introduction.
And thank you all.
I'm overwhelmed by the turnout.
It's great to see
so many people here.
I begin with a diagram.
The caption at the top,
written in a child's hand,
identifies the
circle as the Earth.
Das is die Erde.
The four quadrants are
arranged in a chiastic fashion
along the opposing diagonals.
The diagonal running from
lower left to upper right
marks the distance
between Germany--
Deutschland-- and England.
The opposing diagonal contains
vectors in the form of arrows.
In addition to
attaching text to image,
these pointers set
the orb in motion.
The arrow with the lower
right, which points to Germany,
lends motion and meaning to the
dyadic declaration, da wohne
ich.
I live there.
That at the upper left,
which points to England,
to the equally emphatic
statement, da wohn stu.
You live there.
In its elementary abstraction,
the simple drawing
resembles a medieval
T-O map, in which
the simplest of
geometrical schemata
exemplifies the basic
structure of God's creation.
A typical map of
this kind is far
from being eurocentric
in orientation.
The upper semicircle
represents Asia,
the lower two quadrants
Europe and Africa.
The continents converge on
the world's true center,
the Holy Land, with Jerusalem
sometimes, although not always,
at the middle point.
Such maps indicate that
medieval cartography
was diagrammatic to its core.
To what extent,
however, are diagrams
cartographic, in the
sense of modeling reality
in spatial terms?
No less than a medieval
map, a medieval diagram
embodies a Weltanschauung,
a world view.
If not as literally, then in
its structuring of a reality
thought to govern the world
and mankind's place within it.
The letter from which this
child's diagram is taken
explains the circumstances
of its making.
It begins, in
translation, "Dear Mummy,
Papa made a face like
this when you were here,
and cried like this."
It continues.
"This is the earth,
and on the earth
I see how close we are living."
All these points are
underscored by indexical arrows.
A trio of additional pointers
draws the reader's attention
from the text to the diagram
in the upper left hand corner,
lending added force to
its plaintive affirmation
of proximity, as
if its declaration
of inconsequential
distance could, in fact,
effect a reunion.
Adjacent to the diagram
stands a crudely
drawn face, if not quite
round, then in most respects
no less schematic than
the cartographic schema
with which it's juxtaposed.
The tears to which the
letter refers stream
not from the large
black eyes, but rather
from a second pair above them,
perhaps doubling as eyebrows.
And, as if one pair of
eyes couldn't weep enough,
their duplication adds
weight to the letter's words.
Below the face, a trapezoid,
representing both neck
and torso, extends to embrace
the word, Gesicht, a face.
The overlap assures the
linking of text and image,
as does the long
loop representing
a tie, which knots the two types
of graphic traces together.
The other side of the letter
includes a simple exercise
in English, conducted,
it seems, in anticipation
of the desired reunion.
The letter in question was
written by my mother in 1934,
when she was 10.
She had been left
behind in Leipzig
by her parents, who had already
fled Nazi Germany for London,
where they were seeking
to establish themselves
before bringing over
the rest of the family.
The arrows that
punctuate the letter
lended a hope for
instrumentality.
The paintings of Paul
Klee, whose notebooks
are crammed with diagrams,
deliberately and deceptively
ape the naivete of
children's drawings.
They incorporate arrows and
pointers to similar ends,
transforming his playful
yet haunting images
into diagrams of desire.
Like a medieval diagram of
the micro- and the macrocosm,
Klee's schematic drawing,
Ich, Du, Erde, Welt--
I, you, earth, world--
also mixes iconic and
indexical elements
to diagram the relationship
between the self and the world.
In this case, his eye
and his I-- his self.
The horizontal arrow at
the center pointing from
the teardrop-shaped Du on
the right, labeled, "you--
visible interiorization,
object,"
to the reciprocal Ich on the
left, labeled, "eye and I,"
punning, "artist," traces the
path of optical appearances,
"optical, physical--
uh-- opticalischa Weg?"
I can't quite read it from here.
The orb of the earth placed,
as in a medieval diagram
of the four elements,
at the bottom,
marks one half of an
elliptical pathway
which converges from
above and below,
on the eyeball at the left, the
focal point of all the arrows.
The lower half of the path
represents the earth--
non-optical path of
terrestrial or material
rootedness, or stasis.
In contrast, that at the top,
which traverses the upper
region of the all-embracing
circle, labeled, Welt,
represents the world--
non-optical path of cosmic
communality, or dynamism.
Klee's drawing
encapsulates the argument
presented in his essay, Paths
for the Study of Nature,
from 1923.
By the standards
of common parlance,
clays poetic diagram
could not be farther
from a naturalistic
representation of the world.
Rather than reflecting reality,
however, Clay's poetic diagrams
participate in his
credo of making visible.
In his essay, clay describes the
diagram in the following terms.
Quote, "On the lower
path which gravitates
towards the center
of the Earth lie
the problems of
static balance, which
can be defined with
the words, stand
despite all the
possibilities of falling.
The upper path leads
desire to break away
from earthly attachment
through swimming and flying
to free impetus,
to free movement."
Klee explicitly
identifies his diagram,
which provides a pattern
for his paintings,
as a means of charting desire.
The arrows in my mother's
less ambitious cosmic diagram
are no less indexical.
They not only
convey information,
or express an affective state--
in this case, an overwhelming
case of separation anxiety--
they represent an attempt to
impose order on the world--
in this case, a world in
which order was quickly
slipping away, and in which
nothing would soon make sense.
More an expression of distraught
desire than crude cartography,
the diagram, despite
its simplicity,
raises fundamental questions.
In the words of Nelson
Goodman, "how is worldmaking
related to knowing?"
To paraphrase Goodman's reply,
diagrams do not map the world.
They make a world.
Of course, medieval
authors would not
have accepted Goodman's account
of multiple actual worlds,
although in the
context of discussions
of divine omnipotence,
possible worlds represented
a different matter.
His question, however,
would nonetheless
have made sense to them.
I wish to argue that, no less
than my mother's diagram,
those made in the Middle Ages
should be viewed, not simply
as tools for thinking, or
representations of knowledge,
but also as vehicles
of deeply held desires.
Rather than simply
representing the world,
they make and model worlds.
Diagrams and desire might seem
far removed from one another.
No less a logician than
Charles Sanders Peirce,
however, saw fit
to connect them.
In his essay, "Logic as
Semiotic," written around 1897,
Peirce spoke of the habit of
"abstractive observation," that
formed the foundation of
learning from experience.
Peirce defines the process
in terms of desire.
And this is the first of
a few longer quotations,
so I put them up
for you to follow.
"The faculty which I call
abstractive observation
is one which ordinary
people perfectly recognize,
but for which the
theories of philosophers
sometimes hardly leave room.
It is a familiar experience
to every human being
to wish for something quite
beyond his present means,
and to follow that
wish by the question,
should I wish for that
thing just the same
if I had ample
means to gratify it?
To answer that question,
he searches his heart,
and in doing so,
makes what I term
an abstractive observation.
He makes in his imagination
a sort of skeleton diagram,
or outlying sketch,
of himself, considers
what modifications the
hypothetical state of things
would require to be made in that
picture, and then examines it,
that is, observes
what he has imagined,
to see whether the
same ardent desire is
there to be discerned.
By such a process,
which is at bottom very
much like mathematical
reasoning,
we can reach
conclusions as to what
would be true of
signs in all cases,
so long as the intelligence
using them was scientific.
On Peirce's account,
which remains
indebted to Kant's notion of
the schema of imagination,
namely the rule or
procedure by which
a pure non-empirical concept
or category is associated
with a sense impression,
the process of perception
itself involves a form of
diagrammatic projection.
In this model, diagrams
are not simply something
seen, they are also an inherent
part of constitutive cognitive
patterns, which observers
bring to their experience
of the world.
And just as diagrams
were central to,
even constituentive
of Peirce's logic,
so too I hope to
demonstrate logic
is critical to understanding
medieval diagrams in ways
that have not always
been fully appreciated.
All of you, no doubt, have an
instinctive sense as to what
constitutes a diagram.
Diagrams constitute a
staple of our textbooks,
as Dan pointed out.
Especially in the German
philosophical tradition,
they are thought to
appeal to intuition--
Anschauung.
All the way back
to Plato, diagrams
have been associated with
transcendental truth.
Diagrams, however, at least
as materially produced
and transmitted, are
very much a product
of their time and place.
Despite their association
with laws, logic, and truth,
diagrams have
contingent dimensions.
A diagram, some might say, is
a two-dimensional schematic
representation-- usually
linear or geometric--
of relationships between
various interrelated objects
or concepts, that is designed
to show how something works.
If only it were that simple.
Even this rudimentary definition
is riddled with equivocation,
and makes all kinds
of assumptions.
For starter, with
what one might call
the representational
regime of the diagram.
Does a diagram in some way
reflect or embody reality?
Or does it possess
its own reality,
whether ideational or material?
Are diagrams platonic
or pragmatic?
Moreover, if one is to speak
of the diagrammatic as well
as the diagram, per
se, why need one
limit oneself to two dimensions?
In the age of virtual
reality, diagrams readily
assume three-dimensional form.
Also in logic, in
which tautologies
have given way to typologies.
With the rise of
computer-generated design,
which encourages less the
representation of preexisting
forms than the
playful generation
of perception-bending spaces,
architectural historians
and even some architects refer
to their solid structures
as diagrammatic, not
simply in character,
but also in conception.
Modern design practice
serves as a reminder
that a diagram is always spatial
and relational in character.
Some diagrams, such as the
Feynman, Penrose, and Minkowski
diagrams employed by
physicists to graph spacetime--
and please don't ask me too
many questions about those
after the talk--
and the interactions
among particles,
explicitly integrate
the component of time.
As in the Compendium Historiae
in Genealogia Christi of Peter
of Poitiers, the shift from the
third into the fourth dimension
can unfold or unfurl
on paper or parchment,
not to mention, on
a computer screen.
Diagrams chart.
They map.
They interrelate.
But they also unfold,
sometimes literally.
Diagrams deal with process,
both in the world and no less
importantly, in the mind.
They plot rationality
in spatial terms,
and map out cognitive as
well as mechanical practices
and procedures.
Cognitive psychologists
ask whether spatial schemas
offer a metaphor or a mechanism
for cognitive processes.
Medieval diagrams suggest
that the answer is both.
Take, for example, a single
diagram found in a 14th century
historical compendium from
the Diocese of Konstanz,
consisting of biblical
paraphrases and summaries.
The diagram takes the form
of a seven arm candelabrum,
and in this particular
copy, can be considered
either the last part of Peter
of Potiers' work, with which it
often circulated, or the
first in a series of nine
diagrams at the end of the
manuscript, the remainder
of which belong to the set known
as the Speculum Theologiae.
Its placement alone
permits it to serve
a mediating role between
the historical works, which
constitute the bulk of the
book, and the moralizing
diagrams at the end, whose
emphasis is tropological,
that is, moral, rather
than typological, that is,
historical.
Whereas in an early 13th
century English example
here at Harvard--
it's one of the earliest
surviving copies--
the candelabrum, accompanied
by a Tree of Consanguinity,
comes at the very beginning of
Beiter's Timeline of Scriptural
History.
In the 14th century version,
in which, moreover, the work
has been adapted
from roll to codex,
the candelabrum comes, rather,
at the end, thereby endowing it
with an eschatological aura,
embedded within the text, which
ostensibly explains it.
The diagram
represents the church,
by means of a seven-branched
menorah from the temple.
Transplanted to a
Christian context,
the seven-armed
candelabrum, similar
to monumental bronze
examples found
in churches
throughout the empire,
indicates, as does the
genealogy that precedes it,
that Judaism, synagoga,
has been superseded
by Christianity, ecclesia.
The candelabrum represents
part of the symbolic
as well as the literal beauty
of the church triumphant.
The upright central
arm represents Christ.
The three on one side,
the left, represent
the three orders, or
grades, of the faithful
during the period
before, the three
on the other side, that is the
right, after the Incarnation.
The text, in turn,
defines these three orders
within the church in terms
of the prophecy in Ezekiel
regarding Noah, Daniel, and Job.
Whereas Noah represents
the prelates,
Daniel represents the virgins,
and Job, those who are married.
All await the day of judgment.
Above each of the seven arms
an upturned, chalice-like cup
pours out oil into one
of the bowls held aloft
by the arms, which in turn
consist of pieces which
are linked by small
spheres, from which
spring decorative lilies, terms
which are repeated obsessively
across the surface
of the page, as
if to match the number of
parts in real examples.
And for example, the
candelabrum in Braunschweig,
which I just showed you,
has 74 different parts.
The redundant denomination of
the depicted object's parts
provides a plethora of places--
loci-- not unlike the segments
of the Guidonian hand,
a common mnemonic device.
How does such a diagram work?
The accompanying text barely
makes any mention of it.
Some terms are allegorized.
The majority, however, in
particular the components
of the candelabrum, are not.
In contrast to what one
finds in an authentic work
by Peter, the Allegoriae
Supertabernaculum Moysi.
It is left to the viewer
to make sense of the image.
More than a line diagram, but
less than a freestanding image,
it hovers between two
modes of representation.
The object diagram
figures both time--
sacred history-- and space--
heaven and hell, as
well as the ranks
within the
ecclesiastical hierarchy.
Like the diagram, all of
history and all people
are divided in two by
the coming of Christ.
The image's meaning, moreover,
is conditioned by its context.
Whereas the preceding schematic
rendering of salvation history,
in the form of
Peter's chronology,
identifies the diagram
as an image connecting
past and future, even
as it distinguishes
between the blessed
and the damned,
and by implication,
Christians and Jews,
the subsequent
image, a Tree of Life
based on Bonaventure's
Lignum vitae,
provides a visionary vehicle
for spiritual ascent,
by way of the
imitation of Christ.
In the words of the inscription
at the bottom, a paraphrase
of Apocalypse 22, "I
saw the tree of life
bearing twelve fruits, yielding
its fruits every month.
And the leaves of the tree were
for the healing of nations."
Just as the viewer
of the candelabrum
is instructed that the gifts
which Christ confers on mankind
surpass human understanding,
so too the viewer of the Tree
is invited to ascend with Christ
and aspire to those heights.
Both diagrams serve a mnemonic
function, permitting the reader
to hang various concepts on the
branches of both candelabrum
and tree, just as
does the artist.
The metaphors, however, merge--
a complementarity
encouraged and enhanced
by the fact that
the two images face
one another across an opening.
Alone, by virtue of the
two images' juxtaposition,
the candelabrum becomes a
type of Christ on the cross.
The branches of both
menorah and tree
become intertwined,
generating new associations.
Metaphor becomes
mechanism, a mechanism
whose parts the viewer is
expected to manipulate.
The images both represent a
Christian conception of truth,
and provide the
viewer with vehicles
for striving towards it.
The use of diagrams
as demonstrations,
whether mathematical
or philosophical,
or as vehicles with which
to attain those truths,
is as old as Plato,
Euclid, and Archimedes.
Each of the 42 diagrams
developed by Lothar of Segni,
later Pope Innocent III,
to accompany his Treatise
on the Mass, is paired
with an explanation
beginning, haec
figura demonstrat--
this figure demonstrates.
The repeated rubric
was hardly necessary.
The diagram itself
serve to make the point.
Throughout the
Middle Ages, diagrams
made particular types of
claims on their viewers
and demanded specific forms
of cognitive response.
Philosophical tracts
regularly contain
diagrams, whether to
represent their contents,
or to provide the
reader with tools
for conceptualizing problems.
The diagrammatic tradition's
roots in science--
in particular, astronomy
and cosmology--
made it natural to associate
medieval diagrams with reason
rather than with feeling.
Their abstraction, in
turn, made it easier
to associate them with the
realm of the intellect,
rather than with
that of experience.
Of course, the truth
claims of diagrams
do not need to be
accepted at face value.
In particular, religious
devotional and theological
diagrams, which deal with
such topics as life and death,
prophecy, and salvation, or the
underlying order of creation--
you're looking here at a Genesis
initial from a 12th century
Bible--
necessarily grapple
with powerful emotions,
which, no matter how hard
they try to impose it,
escape the
establishment of order.
Not without reason,
postmodern philosophers
have subjected diagrams
to scathing suspicion,
if for different reasons
than did late 19th century
mathematicians and logicians,
such as Frege, Pasch,
and Hilbert.
Writing on figures such as
Gilles Deleuze, Francois
Laruelle, and Alain
Badiou, a neoplatonist
who elevates set theory
to the role of geometry
in Plato's corpus, the historian
of philosophy, John Mularkey,
has declared, quote, "There
is no Truth in diagrams,
nothing sacred in geometry.
The fluctuous line is not
an intimation of the divine.
Its immanence, its
materiality, keeps it
at some distance from the
infinite lines, pure circles,
and perfect triangles
of Nicholas of Cusa.
Such infinities,
purities, and perfections
smack of the virtual,
the transcendental,
the vision of God."
This iconoclastic
critique of the diagram,
which casts it not as
an instrument of reason,
but rather as a
rhetorical device,
opens its seemingly
cogent demonstrations
of irrefutable logic
to accusations, if not
necessarily of
mystical irrationality,
than at least of fiction
and ideological persuasion.
Following David
Freedberg, art historians
now regularly speak of
the power of images.
Within anthropological
perspectives,
less often is it asked, to
what end such power, whatever
form it might take?
The power that derives
from persuasion, let alone
animation, is very different
from a demonstration
of irrefutable truth.
To what extent do
diagrams lend one
the appearance of the other?
Part of diagram's
persuasive power
lies in their uncanny
ability to both mimic
and to structure the process
of ratiocination itself.
To these functions the
diagrammatic method,
underlying some forms of
artificial intelligence,
bear witness.
Peirce invented a
diagrammatic language
called, by him, existential
graphs, with which he thought
he could address any
philosophical problem,
in particular those in logic.
And this is a set of those
so-called existential graphs
from his notebooks
across the street,
in the Houghton Library.
In a celebrated
passage written shortly
before his death in 1913,
Peirce declared, quote,
"reasoning is dependent
on graphical signs."
Peirce, who said of
Aristotle, and again I quote,
"have read and thought
more about Aristotle
than about any other man,"
echoes the philosopher's
treatise on memory, in which
he observes that, quote,
"it is not possible to
think without an image."
That's the famous
passage from Aristotle.
Neither Peirce nor
Aristotle, however,
refers to
representational images,
whether actual or mental.
And this passage
is often misquoted.
In fact, Peirce insists
that neither on paper,
nor in his dreams, do
his diagrams engage
with the imagination.
This is a wonderful passage.
"There is nothing fanciful
about my diagrams.
I do not, for
example, see numbers
with colors attached to them
and placed upon some curve,
and it perfectly
astounds me to find
how useful some persons
are able to make
such strange constructions.
When I am in health I
am not aware of having
any dreams, unless
perhaps of a problem
in algebra where no real
significations are attached
to the letters, or
something equally abstract.
My 'Existential Graphs'
have a remarkable likeness
to my thoughts about any
topic in philosophy."
In contrast to his approximate
contemporary, the philosopher,
logician, and mathematician,
Gottlob Frege,
whose concept schrift--
Begriffsschrift--
a formal language
for pure thought modeled
on that of arithmetic
represented a
revolution in logic,
but also had the effect of
banishing pictures, even
diagrams.
Peirce insists not
simply on the utility,
but also the
necessity of diagrams.
The stakes here are high.
Moreover, they can
be framed in terms
that a medieval theologian
would have understood.
Namely, what purchase do the
imaginative faculties, which
operate with images,
have on truth?
Just as medieval
thinkers disagreed
when it came to this issue,
with iconoclasts representing
the radical skeptics, so
too modern philosophers
and students of psychology have
swung from one pole to another.
In the words of one
commentator, "we
live at the end
of a period, which
perhaps more than
any other, has hidden
in the pictorial life of the
mind from intellectual view."
Philosophy in the mid-century
regarded sense data
as fictions, arrived
at by bad inference,
and suitable for disposal as
an undergraduate exercise.
It was seriously maintained
that all inner representation
was propositional."
That's the end of the quote.
Peirce's view could not
have been more different.
In his essay on
improving reasoning,
Peirce explains,
"By 'graphical' I
mean capable of being
written or drawn,
so as to be spatially arranged.
It is true that one
can argue viva voce,
but I do not believe
one can go very deeply
into any important
and considerably large
subject of discussion
with calling up
in the minds of one's hearers
mental images of objects
arranged in ways in which
time, without space, is
incapable of serving as the
field of representation,
since in time of two
quite distinct objects
one must be antecedent
and the other subsequent."
In insisting on this spatial
dimension of thought,
Peirce again echoes
Aristotle, who
speaks not of mental pictures,
but rather of diagrams.
Having affirmed that, quote--
this is Aristotle speaking--
"it is not possible to
think without an image,"
the philosopher observes,
for the same effect
occurs in thinking as
in drawing a diagram.
In comparing cogitation
to the process of drawing,
Aristotle goes beyond asserting
that a diagram represents
the content of thought.
Rather, it is the
procedure of producing
the diagram which
resembles, and even enables,
the process of thought.
Both, in his view,
involve a step
by step method of
defining and drawing
relationships that point
towards particular conclusions.
If drawing a diagram and
the process of thinking
represent two sides
of the same equation,
then it is not simply a matter
of thought generating diagrams,
but also of diagrams
generating thought.
Rather than a
representation, the diagram
structures the patterns
according to which one thinks.
The diagram is more than
a mere representation.
It is an active, or operative.
This understanding of the
diagram, not as an illustration
but as a tool for thinking,
and in religious contexts,
a vehicle for transporting
the soul to God,
was of major importance
in the Middle Ages.
When thinking about
medieval diagrams,
Peirce provides a
useful point of entry,
and not only because he
assigns them such importance.
Peirce employed diagrams
not simply to map out
a pre-cogitated
philosophy of signs,
but to generate it
in the first place.
Peirce famously
discusses the diagram
in the context of his complex
differentiation of signs
into three overarching
categories--
icons, indices, and symbols.
In discussing specific
instances of icons,
Peirce defines the diagram
in scholastic terms, which
portray an obsession
with triads worthy
of the medieval
theologian struggling
to understand the Trinity.
Just as theologians
spoke of hypostases
to refer to the
persons of the Trinity
as individuated instantiations
of the Godhead, so Peirce--
and I love this detail--
he converted from Unitarianism
to Trinitarianism--
called his three classes of
individuated icons, hypoicons.
"Hypoicons may roughly
be divided according
to the mode of Firstness--
that is, the
pre-reflexive immediacy
of which they partake.
Those which partake of
simple qualities or First
Firstnesses--" he sounds
like Duns Scotus--
"--are images-- those which
represent the relations,
mainly dyadic, or so regarded,
of the parts of one thing
by analogous relations in
their own parts, are diagrams.
Those which represent the
representative character
of a representamen
by representing
a parallelism in something
else, are metaphors."
Peirce can be heavy going.
Peirce outlines a
hierarchy of connectivity.
Whereas images
involve, in his view,
one-to-one relationships
predicated on shared
qualities--
a kind of phenomenology--
and metaphors,
a higher order set of parallel
relationships that are mediated
without any actual
correspondence among
their component parts--
a kind of metaphysics--
a diagram, which,
in his view, belongs
to the realm of
science, charts forces
that, like vectors, require
that a given object and its sign
possess an analogous structure
of internal relationships.
Peirce sought to
make his system,
which ultimately grew to
embrace a 66-fold classification
of signs,
all-encompassing, yet is
betrayed by the personification
of epistomy, sketched
in the margin of one
of his manuscripts,
his system was as much a
product of compulsive obsession
as of distant speculation.
In laying bare the
contradictions and cracks, even
the breaking points
of his classification,
Peirce's marginalia aped the
function of the often unruly,
ribald, and shape-shifting
images in the borders
of medieval manuscripts.
Oops.
There they are.
Whether or not one
regards them as revelatory
of the philosopher's
unconscious concerns
about the stability
of his system,
his drawings are symptomatic of
tremendous emotional, as well
as philosophical struggle.
Sorry.
I'm now just going to go
back to where I wanted to be.
Peirce's diagram of IT,
part of the triad I, It,
and Thou, an early attempt to
reduce Kant's 12 categories
of understanding to a more
manageable three, once again,
which he drew as he was
working on his treatise,
The Natural History of Words,
provides a compelling example
of diagrammatic contingencies.
Less a table or an
octagon, both words
that have been used
to describe it,
the diagram suggests a
whirling St. Catherine's wheel
of words and vectors, whose
centrifugal forms fly out
from the center.
Rather than charting the
infinite qualities of quantity,
indicated to the right,
the spinning forms
suggest a spiraling centrifuge.
In fact, the drawing's forms
reflect the circular blade
structure of the
turbine, a new technology
whose forms fascinated Peirce--
this is Peirce's drawing
of a turbine on the left--
just as they did
his contemporary,
Henry Adams, who, in perhaps
the most famous chapter
of his autobiography,
The Education of Henry
Adams, the Virgin
and the Dynamo,
describes the great machines at
the Chicago exhibition of 1900,
in Chicago, as a
symbol of infinity.
Adams continues, "As he
grew--" he writes about himself
in the third person--
"as he grew accustomed to the
great gallery of machines,
he began to feel the 40 foot
dynamos as a moral force,
much as the early
Christians felt the cross."
In its linking of
categories of perception
to vectors of motion,
Peirce's drawing
is uncannily reminiscent of
Klee's diagram, Ich Du Erde
Welt. Both embody precisely the
kind of metaphorical ambiguity
that Peirce's
so-called Existential
Graphs sought to eliminate.
On the one hand,
Peirce's diagrams
reveal a determination
to impose order
on the unruly signs
of the world--
I'm sorry-- on the
unruly world of signs.
On the other hand, they suggest
a deep-seated fear of disorder.
This double-faced character,
rational and irrational,
finds its match in medieval
diagrams and marginalia.
And I've deliberately put up an
example of phallic marginalia,
because the image at
the top, by Peirce,
which is a parody of his
own existential graphs,
also contains similar
phallic imagery.
In the Middle Ages,
diagrams acted not only as
instruments of pedagogy,
they also served
as a means of recording,
if inadequately,
prophetic and
visionary experience.
In other cases, in keeping
with their generative as well
as their representational
capacities,
they further provided a
matrix for such experiences.
Diagrams supplied an
armature within which
authors and artists could,
to use the medieval term,
figure those things that
could not be captured
by words and images alone.
To view diagrams as
instruments of mystification
might seem like a
contradiction in terms.
Like their modern counterparts,
medieval diagrams demonstrate.
As soon, however, as one
speaks of demonstration,
a contradiction arises.
The purpose of a demonstration
is to make something clear.
Yet an image
requiring decipherment
can also be used
to veil the truth.
Diagram's potential to
clarify often, if not always,
comes at the expense of
metaphorical misrepresentation.
Does history, or
do concepts, really
unfold like the
ramifications of a tree?
Is the Trinity really
like a triangle?
Even if one could
draw such a figure,
and that is precisely
the point, how
is God like a circle, whose
center is nowhere and whose
circumference is everywhere?
In this double
character of the diagram
lay a large part of
its appeal to medieval
theologians and exegetes.
Metaphor, as Umberto
Eco points out,
referring to Aristotle's
theory of the trope,
has the capacity to
establish new ontologies.
Whether overtly figurative
or merely suggestive
of figuration, the
medieval diagram
participated in a
dynamic dialectic
of revelation and
concealment, one in which
the viewer was invited
to participate.
To look at a theological
or mystical diagram
was not only to be instructed,
it was also to be initiated.
Diagrams not only make visible.
Their abstract, etiolated forms
hint at what remains invisible,
beyond representation.
With this turn, one
could object, or observe
that, at a fundamental
level, a diagram is not
a representation at all.
One could even go so far as to
say that diagrams ultimately
have no object or
referent in the world.
Rather than reflect
the world as it is,
they first identify,
then rearrange its parts
into coherent configurations,
that both reflect
and enable, shape and structure,
our patterns of thought.
There is therefore a poetic
dimension to the diagram.
Like a metaphor,
if less open-ended,
a diagram posits a correlation
among disparate elements,
or figures of those
elements, in order,
not simply to reveal, but
rather to create a tertium
comparationis.
It is, of course,
impossible to press
all diagrams, or even
all medieval diagrams,
into a single mold.
Diagrams remain part of the
culture and historical horizon
which produced them.
For the purposes
of this lecture,
I therefore propose
presenting, very briefly,
a set of diagrams created
in the early 1290s,
by the Dominican Friar,
Berthold of Nuremberg,
on whom I'm currently
completing a book.
According to a pair of
authorial subscriptions,
one at the end of the
first and second parts,
the first dedicated
to the cross,
the second to the
Virgin Mary, the work
was written between
1292 and 1294.
In its complete form,
it survives only
in a single manuscript,
the presentation copy.
Despite the author's name,
the style of the illumination
points to the upper Rhine,
in particular the region
of Lake Constance.
One of the most
ambitious diagrammatic
works from the
entire Middle Ages,
it ostensibly serves as
no more than a supplement
to the famous treatise
by Robanus Maurus
in honor of the Holy Cross,
the celebrated collection
of picture poems composed
shortly before the year 810.
Taking Robanus's magnum opus
as his point of departure,
Berthold traces the entire
history of salvation,
from Adam and Eve
to the end of time,
in an astonishing
120 sections, each
of them prefaced by
a small illustration.
So at left you have the original
work by Robanus Maurus, which
in this manuscript is a
15th century copy, which
can be shown to have replaced
a 13th century original,
that was there from the outset.
And then you have part
one of Berthold's work
in which Robanus's
cosmology is reorganized
to tell the story of salvation
in chronological order.
And then in Berthold's
part two, on your right,
the third part of the
whole, the commentary
on the Virgin, her life
and that of Christ,
are spelled out
in greater detail.
By setting salvation history
in the context of typology,
his work is of a piece with
the great typological handbooks
of his day.
The Biblia Pauperum, the
Speculum Humanae Salvationis,
and the Concordantiae
Caritatis, not
to mention various
scholastic Marian compendia.
Both Robanus and Berthold
represent radical shifts
in what we are accustomed
to thinking of as an image.
Whereas the one shifts image
in the direction of text,
the other shifts image in
the direction of diagram.
Despite its difficulty,
Robanus's commentary
on the cross was copied and
admired throughout the Middle
Ages.
Written in the
early 9th century,
at a time when forms,
such as the figured and--
oops.
What am I doing here?
When forms, such as the figured
and historiated initial, which
combined word and image in ways
that were to become integral
to the formal and expressive
repertory of medieval art,
remained of recent
vintage, Robanus's work
provided a benchmark
of unrivaled complexity
for its integration.
Its reception thus provides
a measure of difference
in medieval aesthetics,
theology, and piety.
Berthold's religious commitments
as a Dominican Friar,
and his attitude towards
images, differed dramatically
from those of his
Carolingian predecessor.
These differences chart an
epic-making shift from cross
to crucifix, from a simple,
stark, all-embracing sign,
to a compelling, heart-rending,
and ultimately abject depiction
of the human body, shown
hanging, not from a sign but,
as in this case, from
a green, living cross.
The differences between
Robanus's original
and Berthold's
re-interpretation chart
the origins and
development of figuration
in medieval art, a
passage from cross
to crucifix, from book to
body, from disembodied sign
to embodied image, that
in itself, and in keeping
with Christian justifications of
anthropomorphic representations
of the Godhead, fulfills
and demonstrates
the doctrine of the incarnation.
More than just signs, diagrams
also embody technique.
Not just knowledge,
but ways of knowing.
In light of the processual
nature of the diagram,
any adjustments to Robanus's
complex, text-image amalgam
therefore testify to
shifting epistemologies,
not to mention shifting
attitudes towards images
in particular, and visual
experience in general.
Whereas Robanus's work
revolves around, and is
in part generated by,
intricate numerology,
having no center other
than the cross itself--
witness on the left his
doubling of the seven
gifts of the Holy Spirit, so
as to be able to rearrange them
as a symmetrical cross--
Berthold's is thoroughly
historical, and hence,
paratactic in structure,
tracing the history of salvation
in terms of typology
from beginning to end.
Whereas the disciplined
construction of Robanus's work
presents itself as a revelation
of a temporal truth, whose
validity is underscored by an
abundance of number symbolism,
Berthold's sprawling
structure, more
devotional and
theological, accommodates
a gradual unfolding of human
events in historical time.
For Robanus, locking
his figurations
within diagrammatic
arrays of words
disfigures the image, stripping
it of its immateriality.
For Berthold, fleshing out
diagrams with figuration
enhanced their ability to affect
the truth of the incarnation.
Development
introduces the danger
of teleology, a progress
from abstraction
to anthropomorphism.
Medieval art, however,
relied on multiple systems
of representation,
the figural as well
as the abstract, the narrative
as well as the hieratic.
Similar cross-contamination
persists
in modern scientific diagrams.
Witness Peter
Galison's distinction,
in scientific imaging,
between the homologous--
that is, retaining logical
relations within that
which is represented--
and the homomorphic--
retaining the form
of that which is represented.
Those are his definitions.
The re-emergence
of the diagrammatic
in the modern avant
garde, in which
figural modes of
representation were largely
abandoned in favor of
various forms of abstraction,
provides further
insight into the forces
at work in medieval diagrams.
In diagnosing the
diagrammatic aspects of Dada,
David Joselit has
spoken, and I quote,
"of an historical rupture
between the textual codes
of the book and the visual
codes exemplified by cinema,
constituting the
ground against which
Dada's spectacular
heteroglossia emerges."
According to Deleuze
and Guattari,
whose concept of the rhizome
is fundamentally diagrammatic,
albeit by definition in the
manner of a distributed nodal
network, not a tree,
the diagram does not
function to represent
even something real,
but rather constructs a
real that is yet to come,
a new type of reality.
In this definition, the diagram
acquires a particular form
of agency.
One might thus ask, is
abstraction an appropriate term
applied to medieval diagrams?
To apply the classic
formula of E. H. Gombrich,
making comes before matching.
Medieval diagrams, again,
make and model of the world,
the only difference being
that there ideations
refer not to a world
to come, except perhaps
in an eschatological
context, but rather
to its prototypical
existence in the mind of God.
that Robanus's
picture poems are all
structured by the exemplary
Christian diagram, the cross,
they also exhibit a
spectacular heteroglossia.
They function simultaneously as
poems, pictures, and diagrams.
Their origins can be traced, not
only to the antique traditions
of picture poems, and opus
geminata, prose and poetry
combined, but also
to the earliest
Christian representation of the
crucifixion, the staurogram,
forged from parts of the Greek
words for cross and crucify.
In some cases, Robanus
imposes diagrammatic elements
on the poems in the form of
geometric or figural shapes.
In other cases, the
shapes themselves
take the form of letters
pregnant with meaning.
In translating
Robanus's treatise
into the diagrammatic mode,
and in literally drawing it out
at such length, Berthold
disturbed its delicate balance
between word and image,
separating the two,
and employing independent
images in the form of colored
diagrams, many accompanied
by figural elements.
The differences in formal
and theological presentation
between the two
authors, one famous,
the other forgotten,
defining two ages--
the first operating
in the aftermath
of Byzantine iconoclasm, the
second in a moment of unchecked
enthusiasm for images.
Both works are
serial in structure--
Robanus's with 28 parts,
Berthold's with 120.
But each is organized according
to different principles.
In the latter, sacred history
is not simply represented,
it is effectively reenacted,
using a medium which itself
incorporates a temporal
and corporeal dimension,
as a result of the diagrams
being placed in sequence,
and because each
diagram implicitly
involves a series
of connections being
drawn in both material and
ideational sense of the word.
In this sense,
Berthold's diagrams
could be said to evolve in the
manner of a mathematical proof,
not only each one
in and of itself,
but also in combination
with one another,
as a series that both
retraces and maps
out the course of
salvation history,
from past to present to future.
Words used to describe the
diagrammatics of computer
graphics applied just as
well to Berthold's method.
Quote, "Here,
syntactic possibilities
extend into time
and space as they
define transposition
operations that
facilitate the dynamic
exploration of information.
Information is entered,
or played against time.
The analyst enters the
diagrammatic space,
and what was formerly
a snapshot now
becomes a flow of information."
That's from an article
about computer graphics.
As an historical form predicated
on dyadic relationships,
typology is fundamentally
diagrammatic in form.
Figura, one of the terms
most commonly employed
in medieval sources
to designate diagrams,
carries within it
the connotations
of the typological figure,
which merely shadows
the truth, which, in
the fullness of time,
will be fully fleshed out.
Berthold effectively fuses the
two connotations of the term--
the one, a geometrical figure,
the other, a prophetic image.
In keeping with the discourse
that identified Old Testament
prophecy as a mere foreshadowing
of Christian truth,
and the incarnation as
the ultimate authorization
of images, the diagram
prefigures and points
towards the visible and
necessary reality of Christ's
coming into the world.
The first diagram of
the Marian treatise
offers an encapsulated
lesson in typology.
It is also modeled
on that most familiar
of logical diagrams, the
square of opposition.
Rooted in Aristotle's
distinction
between contradiction
and contrariety,
the square constituted
a fundamental part
of medieval teaching on logic.
Four concepts or propositions
are placed at the corners.
The top pair, defining the
squares upper horizontal,
represents contrary terms.
The bottom two,
the subcontraries.
Each term at the bottom stands
as the subaltern in relation
to the term directly above
it along the vertical sides
of the square.
The square was applied
to such standard topics
as the relations
of propositions,
the construction of
syllogisms, the mathematics
of musical intervals, and
the relationship of elements
within natural philosophy.
In other words, it could be
found throughout the syllabus.
The square, quite,
simply became part
of every student's toolkit.
Diagrams such as the square
are neither illustrations
of the text which
they accompany,
nor mere adjuncts to argument.
Rather, they are tools
with which to think,
and, in Berthold's hands,
with which to create.
In this example, Adam,
at the upper left,
is the partner, yet
superior of the subaltern,
Eve, who by virtue of having
been formed from Adam's rib,
could be thought of
as literally being
but a part of her
male progenitor.
In the case of Christ
and Mary, the diagram
posits the same relationship,
although in this instance,
just how one represents
the particular, the other
the universal, remains unclear.
The efficacy of the diagram,
however, extends quite far.
Adam supplies the contrary
of the new Adam, Christ.
Moreover, Adam and Mary
like Christ and Eve,
are contradictions
of one another.
Transecting the simple
yet elegant image,
which is rooted in the chiastic
structure of the square
of opposition,
the bipartite tree
easily suggests both the tree of
life and the tree of knowledge.
By using logical
diagrams as his model--
others are based on
the Tree of Porphyry--
Berthold lends his
diagrammatic history
of salvation the force of
a logical demonstration.
Moreover, he does so in keeping
with the pedagogic traditions
of his order.
The square can be found
among the 29 illustrations
in a little book for the
consolation and instruction
of novices, dated around 1300.
Extant at a single
early 14th century
manuscript from the important
Dominican library at Toulouse,
its text nonetheless indicates
that it was approved in 1283
at the general chapter of
the order in Montpellier,
suggesting wider distribution.
The anonymous author elaborates
his diagrammatic didacticism.
"I therefore paint
here certain images
I made so that desolate novices
might find consolation in them
and so that a little flame of
newly fervent and more devout
devotion might be kindled
making perceptible matter
from celestial signification."
The images, the
diagrams included,
are intended to ignite
devotional desire.
The novice is instructed
in great detail
in these necessary arguments,
not simply how to read,
but even how to lay out
the diagrams, step by step.
What follows, however,
are not instructions
in how to use the diagram
to solve problems in logic,
but rather how to
apply a moral gloss.
And this becomes clear in
the subsequent illustration,
in which process is key.
The product of this procedure
is this the second diagram,
whose construction and meaning
the text explains at length.
Whereas the text asks
the reader to populate
the preexisting
diagram with scenes
from the parable of
Dives and Lazarus,
the miniature fleshes out the
image right before his eyes,
within an armature
that structures
the process of interpretation.
And the relationship between the
various parts of the parallel
is mapped onto the
square of opposition.
And I won't read you
the text at any length,
because the moralizing is,
as usual, rather dreary.
Other works of the period,
Tomasin von Zerklaere's Der
welisch gast, a didactic work
in the vernacular addressed
to a literate,
aristocratic readership,
likewise assumes easy
familiarity with the square.
You see an image from
one manuscript here.
And so, to come full circle, and
I am approaching my conclusion.
To come full circle,
we also find the square
embedded within the sacred
genealogy represented
by Peter of
Poitiers' Compendium,
here in the same
manuscript I showed you
at the beginning of this talk.
And I don't think it's been
noticed before that Peter also
makes use of the
square of opposition.
Techniques of representing
logical and genealogical
relationships overlap in
Peter's representation
of the complicated line
of descent from Solomon.
To clarify these
tangled relationships,
and to make them
easier to remember,
Peter provides a diagram based
on the square of opposition.
Nathan and Melchi, the two
husbands in that order of Este,
placed at the center, occupy
the roundels constituting
the upper right and left
corners of the square.
Whereas the sons of
each of those unions,
Jacob and Eli,
respectively, occupied those
at the lower right and left.
Nathan and Jacob represent
the direct line of descent
indicated by the thick red
line, which connects Nathan
to his ancestor, Solomon, above,
and to his descendant, Joseph,
below.
The horizontal bar
connecting the two fathers
reads, "connected because
killed," a reference to Melchi
having succeeded Nathan,
following the latter's
death as Este's wife.
Mapped onto the
square of opposition,
their relationship is contrary,
insofar as they cannot have
been married to the same
woman simultaneously.
The bar connecting Eli and
Jacob, the two sons, reads,
uterine brothers, identifying
them as stepbrother's
by the same mother.
Mapped onto the square
in the same fashion,
their relationship, analogous
to that of their fathers', is
subcontrary.
The vertical lines
connecting fathers and sons
read, carnal sons, the
equivalent in the square
to subalternation.
Finally, the diagonals linking
the two fathers via Este
to the two sons,
read, conjugal son.
These represent the lines
of contradiction connecting
the corners, in that Nathan
is not the father of Eli,
and Melchi, in turn, is
not the father of Jacob.
And if you don't remember
that, the square of opposition
would provide you with a
handy little mnemonic device
in order to do so.
It is time to steer
toward some conclusions.
What better way to work them
out than in an imagined diagram?
I envisage not a line,
leading either forward
from the Middle
Ages to modernity,
or backwards from the present
to the past, but rather
a parallelogram, in which
analogous relationships undergo
similar shifts, if
to different ends.
Whether medieval
or modern, diagrams
mix modes of expression,
visual and verbal.
Diagrams are not
only conceptual,
they are also material.
Process is not only
part of their making,
but also their meaning.
Diagrams do not simply
reflect or embody ideas,
they shape them.
And beyond ideas, they move like
machines, to encourage action.
Diagrams are relational.
And very often, as in the
case of Robanus and Berthold,
they are serial.
As for Berthold,
his way of thinking
about the history of
salvation, typology,
which pairs Christian event
to Old Testament prophecy,
and uses geometry to
lend those pairings
the character of a
demonstrative proof,
is fundamentally diagrammatic.
Whether looking at
modern or medieval art,
one can ask the same question.
Why resort to diagrammatic
modes of representation
in the first place?
The answers, whether to
demonstrate cosmic harmony,
provoke visions, understand the
prophetic course of salvation
history, or, in the case
of more modern examples,
to disrupt established
social codes,
will differ dramatically.
One thing, however,
remains constant.
The diagram, on its
face a cold abstraction,
permits one to delve
into the desires that
informed its makers.
In this respect,
diagrams themselves
map what is perhaps the
primary point of intersection
between the technical
and the cultural.
Icons, once a source of mystery,
have become as commonplace
as a computer screen.
The internet and
the worldwide web
purport to displace traditional
centers and hierarchies
in favor of rhizomatic,
distributed networks--
in effect, diagrams
or systems best
understood in terms of diagrams.
Of this desire
disruption, bitcoin
is a paradigmatic example.
Taken together,
such developments
have transformed not only
academia, but also society.
And in the age of
social networks,
human actors
themselves have become
diagrams, defined less in terms
of a stable, autonomous self--
if any such thing ever existed--
than of a system
of relationships
that go by the name of networks.
It is no less the case
that the algorithm, which
even if not a diagram in
itself is best understood
in diagrammatic terms, has,
in a manner of speaking,
become the platonic form
of everyday existence, both
underlying and informing the
reality of contemporary life.
Diagrams are central to
all those disciplines
which deal with the
visualization of knowledge,
as well as, no less important,
the critical discourses
that consider the
impact of modern media
on ourselves and on our society.
As more and more forms of social
interaction become networked,
and as all human activity comes
to be defined in terms of links
within a larger web,
our world and ourselves
increasingly come to resemble
the mechanics of a diagram.
What, one might reasonably
ask, does any of this
have to do with the Middle Ages?
One way in which medieval art
resonates with the present
is that much, although
not all of it,
is fundamentally diagrammatic.
In lieu of linear or continuous
narrative of a kind brought
to perfection in antiquity,
medieval art, so much of which
is predicated on typology,
lends itself to demonstrative,
didactic, and diagrammatic
modes of image making.
The complex armatures
of stained glass windows
provide only the
most obvious example.
Cathedral facades are another.
Medieval authors
and artists seized
upon traditions of scientific
illustration rooted
in antiquity to create
complex representations
of Christian cosmology.
These, in turn,
often imbued ornament
with cosmological significance.
Medieval art is not
simply symbolic, abstract,
an anti-naturalistic, it is
structured and systematic
in its approach to
representing a world which
it perceived as being
highly structured in itself.
History, far from
being open-ended,
had a structure-- one that could
be investigated and manifested
in the language of geometry.
There was, however, no single,
medieval Weltanschauung.
Multiple theologies,
cosmologies, and epistemologies
competed, and
continued to compete
to claim the mantle of
just interpretation.
It is within this contested
field, modern as well as
medieval, linking
diagrams to thought
in the search for truth,
that the subject of diagrams
and the diagrammatic in
the Middle Ages and--
sorry.
It is within this contested
field, modern as well
as medieval, linking
diagrams to thought
and the search for truth,
that the subject of diagrams
and the diagrammatic in
the Middle Ages and beyond
becomes so compelling.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I realize time is
getting on, but I
would love to entertain some
questions, if there are any.
Don't be shy.
And I'll just say, there
are microphones to use.
I started with this image
of a medieval classroom
with two Greek
students discussing
the proverbial problem
of squaring the circle--
it's from a 13th century
English manuscript--
to picture the dialogue
that I hoped we would have.
So you can't disappointment me.
In your last slide, if you
could go back to you last slide?
By all means.
Just a moment.
Actually, this
was my last slide.
But we can go.
This one.
No, the square.
With a cross.
This?
Yeah.
On the left.
Is there is a story
embedded in the square?
It's not prose.
It's a poem.
In one of the many Latin meters
that Robanus Maurus employed.
And the way these
picture poems work,
it's quite mind boggling--
I think of them as a
combination between the world's
most complex crossword
puzzle and sudoko--
is that the text can
be read continuously
from left to right,
top to bottom,
the way you would
read a normal text.
And it reads as Latin verse.
But you can also read
the so-called in-text.
That is, the text
within the figures--
in this case, a simple cross--
as independent verses
in their own right.
This is one of the simpler
examples in the work.
In other words, some letters
serve a double purpose.
They make sense within two
different semantic units,
which are superimposed
one upon the other.
And very often, the arrangement
of words and letters
is governed by very complex
numerological considerations.
It's quite mind
boggling, how anyone
could produce such a thing.
But as we know from
concrete poetry,
and poets like Mallarme,
or Apollinaire,
there's a long, long
tradition, not only in
the west but also in
the Greek tradition,
and in other cultures as
well, of picture poems.
Poems that double as
text and as image.
A famous example within
English literature
would be George Herbert,
in the 17th century.
If you look at some of the poems
in his collection, The Temple,
they take the form
of picture poems.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah.
It reminded me of
a word crossword,
where you have to
find the word with--
Yes.
Well.
These works are not designed to
be understood at first glance.
They're designed to be
meditated on at great length,
in true monastic tradition.
Irene, did you have a question?
I'm pondering it still.
When you discussed Peirce--
Sorry.
When you discussed Peirce,
you used the word, model.
And how a model
relates to a diagram.
Might be, perhaps, unpacked
a bit further by you.
But also, it occurred to me
that there is a difference
between a model and a metaphor.
And to the extent that a
diagram can be read as metaphor
or as model, it would make
an interesting distinction.
I wonder what your thoughts are.
Yes, well, I am not
going to be categorical.
Because in some ways I'm more
interested in the slippage
between those two
types, or categories.
I think the case
of Peirce-- and I
don't claim to have
read everything
that Peirce wrote that is
directly relevant to the topic,
let alone have understood it--
but I think in Peirce's case,
he very much wants it
to be model or form,
but very often it
slips into metaphor,
in ways that he finds
deeply unsettling.
One of the things I find so
fascinating about the drawings
in his manuscripts, which have
only recently begun to receive
any kind of attention, as in
so many other cases, editions
of texts, the drawings, the
diagrams, the marginalia,
simply get edited out.
But one could make
the case that they
are, as it were, the
unconscious of his text.
Although I think he was very
much aware of the problems.
And so the drawings,
as I said, I
think produce metaphoric
nightmares for him.
Even though he insists
that he dreams only
in algebra, which I find one of
the most remarkable statements
I've ever read.
Obviously, I could go further.
But I think that debate as to
whether diagrams are models
and metaphors, is in part,
for example, the debate that
has played out in the
history of mathematics,
from the mid-19th century.
And in both mathematics
and philosophy,
there was a desire exemplified
by logicians such as Frege,
and mathematicians
such as Hilbert.
And I would never claim that I
understand their mathematics.
But they rejected geometry
and diagrams 100%.
They wanted to convert all of
mathematical representation
into algebra.
And since-- I would say--
well, it's really co-equal
with the advent of computers.
Diagrams have, of course,
made a tremendous comeback,
not simply as practical
tools, but also
as legitimate vehicles for
philosophical and mathematical
analysis.
And so there is this debate
amongst mathematicians,
historians of mathematics,
but also cognitive scientists,
as to the validity of diagrams.
To what extent they
represent thought processes,
model thought processes,
or are merely metaphors
for thought processes.
I don't claim to
have the answer.
Yeah, Robin.
Thank you, Jeffrey, for
that wonderful talk.
It may be fanciful,
but I've long
wondered whether part
of Peirce's addiction
to the triadic
notion of semiosis
was related to the fact that
he spent decades working
for the US Coastal Survey,
and engaged in triangulation
as a matter of daily practice.
So I'm wondering if you
have any speculations
about the relationship between
the diagrammatic impulses
in the Middle Ages
and to other practices
outside these beautiful
works that you're showing us,
whether liturgical
practices or what
have you, that might shed some
light on the diagrams we're
seeing?
Thank you for that
wonderful question, Robin.
I'm trying to think on my feet.
In Peirce's case,
he was certainly
obsessed with
triads, which is why
I relish that detail of his
conversion from Unitarianism
to Trinitarianism.
I'm not sure what is
cause and what is effect.
Although the phenomenon you
point out-- surely those years
of working in the Survey
ingrained certain habits
of mind, that could have
had a powerful impact,
or formative impact, on
his patterns of thinking.
Your question makes
me think of a concept
rather like Baxandall's
"period eye."
For those of you who've read
his book on art and experience
in Renaissance Italy,
there's a famous passage
in that book in which
he talks about barrel
making, and barrel gauging
in Renaissance Florence.
And he argues that the way in
which 15th century mercantile
patrons would have sized up,
to use the term advisedly,
would have sized up the
volumetric representation
of objects in three dimensional
space and in perspective
was conditioned by the
tools of their trades.
I mean, one of the
problems with Baxandall
is that you never
quite know where
to draw the line in
defining the period eye.
In terms of the-- guess the
case that I'm making here,
and more extensively in
the book I've written,
is that that practice is logic.
And if one reads the history
of diagrams in the Middle Ages,
there is some attention
given to logical diagrams.
For example, if you read
John Murdock's amazing book,
The Album of Science-- he was
an historian of science here
at Harvard--
still, by far, the best
book on medieval diagrams.
He has a chapter devoted
to logical diagrams,
but there is no attempt
to think of logic diagrams
and the patterns of
thought that they represent
as exemplary, or as
models for other systems
of representation.
Whereas part of what
I want to argue,
and I tried to
demonstrate it briefly,
is that you have an
historian and theologian,
like Peter of Poitiers, who's
using logical diagrams as a way
of structuring his works.
You have Berthold
of Nuremberg who's
making extensive use of
porphyrion logic diagrams,
and the square of opposition,
to structure his diagrams
as an exegetical tool.
So I don't I don't know if
the realm of logic and logic
diagrams is far enough outside,
to answer your question.
But that's the answer with which
I'm comfortable at this point.
I think part of
what I want to do
is argue that logic,
and the modes of thought
and representation
associated with it,
are paradigmatic when it comes
to diagrams, to a greater
extent than has been argued.
So for example, if you
think of the famous diagram
of the triangle
representing the Trinity.
That is a logic diagram,
because the various corners
are connected by the
words, est, non est--
is and is not.
So it's dealing-- it's a kind
of triangle of oppositions.
So that's about the
best answer, for now,
I can get to your question.
Yes.
I believe, in the case
of logical diagrams,
it would be appropriate to
distinguish the mnemonic tools,
if you like, like logical
square, and on the other hand,
in your presentation, you
had also Venn diagrams.
Venn diagrams, semantic
tableaux, kernel maps,
are more than visual tools.
They are demonstrative,
and deductive, it you like,
artifacts that can be used.
So this is a distinction.
And mind maps more
for, if you like,
brainstorming and
creative usage.
Which are also--
Yes.
Yes, I think that's an
important distinction.
But of course, one
of the reasons why--
if I remember my history
of logic correctly--
one of the reasons why
Peirce worked so obsessively
on his existential
graphs, is because he
felt that there were
problems with Venn diagrams,
and he wanted to
improve on that system.
And recently, there's
an historian--
not an historian-- a logician
at Yale who has written
on Peirce's existential graphs,
with a view to demonstrating,
or trying to demonstrate
to her satisfaction--
I've forgotten her
name for the moment--
that Peirce's system
actually is an improvement.
And that it works.
Again, I am not
sufficiently sophisticated
in order to come to any
final judgment myself.
But the fact that
such a debate exists
demonstrates that logicians
themselves continue
to grapple with the
question, to what degree
a diagram has probative value.
For example, in the
history of mathematics,
there are debates about Euclid.
And there is a lively
literature arguing
against those who have taken
the position that Euclid's
diagrams are problematic.
That they do not actually
prove the propositions
they supposedly demonstrate.
And yet recently, there are
historians of mathematics
who have made that case.
Now as for the square
of opposition--
and this is perhaps the last
thing I'll say in response
to your very important
distinction--
the square of
opposition was long
written off as a kind
of simplistic tool
for novices in logic,
despite the fact
that, well into
the modern period,
it was of such importance in
the syllabus and curriculum.
But even the square
of opposition
is making a comeback.
And there have been conferences
with hundreds of contributions
devoted to the
square of opposition
and its various applications.
So without wanting to
adjudicate beyond my ken,
it's interesting that,
as in the case of Euclid,
so too in the case
of the square.
There are now some
logicians who argue
that a case can be made for
it, in certain contexts.
I hope that goes some way
to answering your question.
Yes, Dan.
Well, let me thank you again for
that wonderful and stimulating
talk.
I would like to pick up on a
detail from Robin's question
and push it in a
different direction,
because you began
with a T-O map.
And early on, you
had a map of, I
think it was from Matthew
Paris, with a flap extending up.
Yes.
And it raised a
question for me about,
what is the relationship
between the map and the diagram?
Is one a subset of the other?
Is there an easy overlap
between those two?
What other plans do
you have this evening?
Dinner.
Yes.
Me too.
That's an exceptionally
fraught question.
Obviously, if you think of
a kind of sliding scale,
there's a point at which
maps become diagrammatic,
and at which some diagrams
become cartographic.
And they both deal
with spatiality,
in some ways that are related.
Some people have said that,
unlike diagrams, maps have
real reference in the world.
And again, I don't want
to seem like a cop out,
but I think that I would
have to take it on a case
by case basis.
I mean, maps are fascinating
in that, as we all know,
there's something
arbitrary about any form
of cartographic representation.
And that's why I
used the comparison
to talk about a kind
of Weltanschauung.
Medieval maps happen to
be, for the most part,
exceptionally diagrammatic.
I'm not sure I would call
Google Maps diagrammatic,
although, if you
look at the under--
if you could strip
away the imagery,
and look at the
underlying software--
that again, without
knowing what that is--
but I imagine that if you
stripped the images away,
and could just see how
it works, whether it's
based on algorithms
or whether it's
based on certain kinds
of projective geometry,
that it is fundamentally
diagrammatic as well.
Yes.
Thank you very much.
Actually, you just answered
the first half of my question
about the difference
between diagram and map.
I guess my other question
was, what happened?
What was the afterlife of
the circling of the square?
Of course, it is a very--
I haven't solved the problem.
It's a very, very
important figure
for writers, such as Dante, of
course, and so on and so forth.
And it persists as
a figure of thought
into the Renaissance period.
And I was just
wondering whether it
was absorbed, since
it stopped being
represented diagrammatically.
Was it absorbed by
some other media?
Well, again, I seem to be
answering every question
by saying, I don't know.
But I imagine
that, if one looked
through the very extensive
corpus of school books
and treatises about pedagogy
and the seven liberal arts,
that one might find and prints
some representations of it.
But that I don't--
that I don't know.
Obviously, the notion
of squaring the circle
has become proverbial.
To that extent, it's
survived as the problem
that is impossible to solve.
Although, of course, calculus
makes it a little bit easier.
I should let all of you
know that I virtually failed
mathematics in high school.
So I feel I'm really
skating on thin ice.
But that's also part of what has
made this line of investigation
so fascinating for me.
You know, better
late than never.
So the image I showed you of the
two figures engaged in debate,
brandishing their
squared circles,
that's an unusual image.
There is a whole iconography
of the classroom in the Middle
Ages.
And Laura Cleaver has recently
written an interesting book
precisely on that subject.
But it's not as if there
was a pictorial tradition
of illustrating that problem.
Of course, there are
many medieval images
that consist of a circle
or circles in a square.
I could show you
those ad infinitum.
In multiple media.
And that geometry is more
than just a decorative device,
or a framing device.
Although frames are of critical
importance in medieval art,
it is a way of imposing a kind--
or implying a kind of
cosmological order.
I'm afraid beyond
that, I'm not sure I
can answer your question.
Yeah.
Gina?
Thank you, Jeffrey.
That was wonderful.
And I am sure I can
ask you a question
that you will know
the answer to.
That is, sort of following up
on the questions about, I guess,
imagery, this
diagrammatic impulse--
and you put up how figuration
and diagrammatic impulse
go together in Berthold's case.
And I wonder if there
is ever a sort of impact
on artistic practice itself.
That the images of
figuration actually
get, like diagrammatic impulse,
translated into it, in a way?
I'm just coming from
a tradition-- thinking
about a tradition that develops
am iconometric system that
sort of transposes that
diagrammatic thinking
onto the body?
So human figures and
figurative representation.
Well, it's interesting.
If we were to page through
Villard de Honnecourt's
so-called sketchbook--
it's not a sketch book.
It's not even
really a model book.
You would find
many stick figures
based on geometric figures.
And there, clearly,
it's being used
as a mnemonic device for
craftsmen to generate figures,
or to remember how to
produce a certain figure.
Architecture becomes
very problematic,
but I think it's fair to say--
setting aside symbolic geometry,
which is often very difficult
to establish, much
as scholars like
to project it onto buildings--
geometry plays a generative
role in medieval architecture.
And certainly, in
medieval images.
Just the tools they
used-- ruler, compass.
It lent itself to
geometric armatures.
But those armatures also
served as mnemonic devices.
But more important,
I think, as I
received way of generating
variations on a theme.
In the case of
manuscripts, of course,
you have the ruling on the page.
And even the pages that
have illuminations on them,
as received by the
painter, they're already
ruled, because these
craftsmen or scribe who
did the ruling didn't
know, in most cases, where
the pictures would fall.
And artists do use that ruling
as a matrix for their pictures.
Not always, but
very, very often one
can show, even in the
later Middle Ages,
where illuminators are using
more naturalistic modes
of representation, that they
are employing the underlying
ruling as a kind of
pre-established graph paper,
if you will.
Yeah.
Yeah, Rosha?
Thanks, Jeffrey, for
this inspiring talk.
I'm so looking
forward to the book.
There's a solid Jeffrey
bookshelf in my office.
So, especially in
the case of Berthold,
as you have beautifully
showed and argued,
there's this shift towards
anthropomorphization,
from the cross to the crucifix.
And it strikes me that
Berthold's diagrams
are so figurative, and
that's part of his time.
That's part of the development.
I understand that.
But my question is
the underlying metric
is still the cross, isn't it?
So it still goes back to that.
But then, how does
script come into it?
So is it also script that
makes, especially when we
look at this image, makes
it a mnemonic diagram?
So my question, I
guess, is what's
the relationship between
figurative representation
and script?
Yeah.
Well--
That's huge, I know.
No, no.
But a lot of these images do
involve changing constellations
of word and image.
And as you say, that's huge.
To indulge in a really
gross generalization,
you could say that the history
of medieval art, certainly
from the Carolingian
period onward,
in which text and
image are fused
in a variety of
very formative ways,
historiated initials
first appear
in the Carolingian period.
These picture poems are
another salient example.
That the whole history of
medieval art from that point
forward involves a gradual
teasing out, and separation
of the two elements.
So that by the Gothic period,
for example, text and image
have largely, if
not entirely, been
extricated from one another.
Of course, you find historiated
initials in the Gothic period,
but not in the way
that one would, say,
in Romanesque manuscripts.
And then, of course,
by the 15th century,
you can think of
book illustration,
in a way rather similar to the
way in which we still think
of book illustration, with
text and image divorced
from one another, but
still related in some ways.
To take this particular
example, the inscriptions
here are selected verses
from the carmina figurata,
from the picture
poems of Robanus.
Sometimes abbreviated,
but they're actually
incorporated in some cases
in rather awkward ways.
They're simply placed
around the images,
wherever he can fit them in.
And that awkwardness actually
attests to this disintegration
of the two media.
Yes, at the back?
Yeah, hi.
You said a thing earlier that
I thought was interesting.
You said you were interested in
the slippage between metaphor
and model.
And it reminded me of--
you also mentioned Deleuze a
lot, which I commend you for.
Deleuze has this
concept, you know,
of abstract machines, where
you sort of take a concept,
or a logic that normally
wouldn't apply in another area,
and you map it onto
another area, just
to see what you sort
of get out of it.
And so I'm wondering
if there are
any historical
examples of people
doing that sort of a thing.
Not like concepts,
like Deleuze does.
Like, you know,
he'll use concrete.
But people forget the
concrete was in liquid form
before it's formed,
and so people will
be like, this isn't concrete.
That sounds like fluid.
Do people do anything like
that, that you know of,
with pictorial
diagram explicitly?
To be productive
with their diagrams,
in that sort of a way?
If that makes sense.
Medieval thinkers could
be very, very playful
in speculative ways.
You know, witness
the discussions
of what would have
happened if you assume
the complete free
will of God, and if he
had come to save mankind
in the form of an ass,
instead of a man.
So they weren't beyond
entertaining wild hypotheticals
in order to make certain
kinds of arguments.
They occasionally got
in trouble for that.
But I think to that
extent, Deleuze
and the typical medieval
thinker are really
very, very different.
In that, as I
understand him, Deleuze
is always interested in
that kind of disruption
and in breaking
down of hierarchies.
That's why he attacks the tree
as opposed to the rhizome,
and the tree is perhaps
the archetypal metaphor
diagram of the Middle Ages.
There's a wonderful article by--
or essay by Umberto
Eco, by the way,
called, "From Tree
to Labyrinth,"
which explores very much the
same set of ideas, in, I think,
very brilliant ways.
I was thinking-- if
I could help at all--
Sure.
Because Deleuze says that the
point of philosophy is to--
like, what philosophers do,
and the point of philosophy
is to create concepts.
And he has a few
parts where he also
says that sometimes
you need a tree
and other times
you need a rhizome.
So I think he's doing more
of like a differential,
or binary sort of thing there,
than just privileging one
over the other.
And so I guess I
was just wondering
if there would be a medieval
example of someone taking,
just, like, some crazy--
I don't know-- botanical
drawing, and then saying like,
well, now, let's see
how this explains--
Well I think--
Makes sense of something else.
I think you could make the
case that a medieval thinker
or artist could press
just about anything
into a diagrammatic mode.
And again, speaking in terms
of gross generalizations,
I would argue that, as
opposed to narrative,
as opposed to even allegory,
that the diagrammatic
is perhaps the dominant
mode in medieval art.
And I'm not the
first to say that.
Others have pointed
that out as well.
They've also made the
connection with typology
as a mode of thought.
I'm not sure I agree with
you completely about Deleuze,
although I expect
you're more widely read
than I am in his works.
But if you read that
introductory section
of his text on the rhizome,
it's just a scathing attack
and criticism of all
forms of, you might say,
arboreal thought.
I think it's meant to be
deeply, deeply subversive,
in a way that I think
is unthinkable for most
medieval authors.
But certainly, in
the same way that,
you know, in the Dada
diagram that I showed you.
If you read Joselit's
analysis of those diagrams,
he makes the case that
their agenda was, again,
fundamentally subversive
and disruptive
of established social norms.
That's just not the way
that medieval art works,
in most cases.
I nonetheless think that
it's very instructive
to apply the thinking of some
of these modern philosophers
to the medieval works.
And vice versa.
Yeah.
Thanks.
I don't want to keep
anybody from their dinner.
Yes.
One more question at the back?
A very short question.
You mentioned shortly--
or you spoke mostly
on two-dimensional diagrams,
and mentioned shortly
the three-dimensional diagrams.
And I was wondering what
about the fourth dimension?
What about the movement
or the temporality?
How does that come into
play in reading diagrams,
or in creating diagrams,
or could even a movement
be part of a diagram?
That would be my question.
Absolutely.
In terms of the thought process
itself as being processual.
In terms of the
making of the diagram,
obviously, there's
a temporal aspect.
And in the Dominican treatise
that I referred to, at the end,
it tells you step by step,
how to draw the diagram,
and it could have been
done in a different way.
But he allegorizes the
process of drawing it.
Having told you how
to do it, because he
wants you to think
of its construction
in a particular way.
The element of time
is what fundamentally
distinguishes Berthold's
rewriting of the work.
You could say, again
speaking crudely,
that whereas Robanus's work
is centered on the cross,
and everything means the cross,
and in a sense it's atemporal,
it's eternal, Berthold's
is put into the model
of salvation history.
And that's why he has
to completely reorder
Robanus's structure.
Because, as a 13th
century Dominican,
he's interested in salvation
history, and in time,
and in history in ways
that Robanus simply wasn't.
And he's interested
in images in a way
that Robanus
couldn't be, because
of the context of
iconoclastic debates.
And then, as I tried to show
in the Peter of Poitiers,
where you have a timeline,
the temporal element
is inscribed within the work.
But I don't even think you need
to stop with four dimensions.
I mean, since I
mentioned David Hilbert,
you know, he's most famous for
so-called Hilbert spaces, which
can involve an infinite
number of dimensions.
Which I gather is why Hilbert
spaces are of such interest
to physicists and
string theorists.
Don't ask me any questions.
But there you're dealing
with, as it were, diagrams
in an infinite number of
dimensions, of vector spaces,
and an infinite
number of dimensions.
And now I'm really talking about
something I know nothing about.
So thank you very
much to you all.
[APPLAUSE]